a lot of parents and teachers are
confused about what to do because they
can't get through on these hotlines many
of them waiting several hours now ccsd
telling us these long waits are expected
after a long winter break
we called the hotline all day monday all
day tuesday genevieve dawson says she is
trying to figure out how to get her
child back to school after having
testing positive for copin 19. we called
the school back again and they said they
still didn't know what to tell us she is
like many other parents trying to call a
district hotline for guidance she's
feeling better she hadn't had any more
symptoms so i took a chance sent her
back to school had them had her ask the
school
when she got there
and they didn't send her home we called
the hotline and either got this message
i'm sorry but we are at maximum call
volume or this tone
that first day i tried calling like 30
times and every single time i received
the message
um i'm sorry the system we've reached
maximum call volume goodbye teachers are
frustrated too despite testing negative
vicky tiny lives with someone who tested
positive she has to call the health line
to get cleared to go back to work they
told me that i cannot return until
the system clears me so without getting
through
i can't go back to work ccsd tells us as
expected after the long break call
volume to the parent health line was
higher than normal ccsd worked to adjust
staffing to increase efficiency and the
dedicated staff is being thorough to
ensure the health and safety of students
and employees four or five hours on hold
is excessive and i don't know who's able
to do that
now back out here live another question
we tried to ask ccsd the communications
department there is exactly how many
people are operating these phone lines
but they did not answer that question
reporting live this evening john mullen
live local now